the u.s. system is designed to do
nothing all right so that means to get
something passed and to become a law you
need a majority in the house you need a
supermajority in the Senate you also
need the President to sign it and that's
aside from other institutional
constraints like the committee system
and so on all right so when the
Democrats hold the majority and the
Democrats hold the White House the u.s.
system is going to restrain their agenda
that's just the way the system is that's
the way the founders intended what we do
in this study is to try to ask the
question why why has the institution
evolved to look the way it does and so
what we do is we examine two
much-maligned aspects of the u.s.
political institution the supermajority
rule and the delegation of authority to
bureaucrats both of these are can be
seen as undemocratic the filibuster rule
in that it's not respecting majority
rule it's not representing the people as
well as it should and the delegation to
bureaucrats who are unelected all right
so it's often asked why he's already
delegated to these sorts of people who
aren't elected by the people
what we find is that these two
components the supermajority filibuster
rule and the delegation of authority to
unelected bureaucrats on their own seem
very undemocratic but together if they
work in such a way that their
interdependence actually leads to better
policy outcomes then we otherwise would
achieve what most analyses or most
commentary on the gridlock misses is
that there's a lot of action happening
in the background and what we're trying
to point out is a lot of this action is
happening via delegation so Congress may
fight they may be able to may not be
able to agree about whether the tax rate
should be a little higher or a little
lower but what they can agree upon in a
world that's changing over time is that
they want policy to be smoothed out in a
sense to not change too much as the
world changes to react to the changing
world because one thing that politicians
like particularly incumbent politicians
is they like the status quo they like
the world to not change because that
world is what got them elected and so as
much as they can they'd like to keep the
world the way it is gridlock serves that
purpose and so to that extent it's kind
of locking down the world or locking
down some policies for the interests of
these policymakers that allows deals to
be made in Congress and what we're
trying to show in this research is that
delegation is a way that Congress can
overcome the problems of gridlock and
get deals done
so to take a recent example we can look
at the dodd-frank bill where are lots of
authority was relegated to the financial
regulators now that may have been a
puzzle why didn't Congress they there's
nothing more sailing or nothing more
important in the last five years then
financial reform why didn't Congress
figure out the answer themselves what
they did was they delegate authority to
the regulators because they didn't know
how the world was going to change what
Congress people could agree upon is that
they wanted to find a solution and they
didn't know what it was and they didn't
know what it would be tomorrow but the
deal they struck was to delegate that
authority to a regulator who had
different preferences to them so it may
seem undemocratic but it's those
different preferences that allow the
deal to happen yesterday Democrats and
Republicans agreed something needed to
be done they could agree they didn't
know what it was but they could agree to
delegate authority to that agency
tomorrow when the agency starts figuring
out what the answer is Republicans or
maybe Democrats don't like it but they
can't backtrack they can't roll it back
precisely because of gridlock
gridlock has its pluses and has its
minuses all right it does stop things
from happening and it frustrates a lot
of people what we're trying to show here
is the gridlock may not be as bad as it
bad as it seems and that other aspects
of the political institution go a long
way to solving the problems or solving
the inefficiencies of gridlock